it ended with the being bold and taking
bold stances he came out against
Birthright citizenship I thought that
was very cool I he V takes a lot of bold
stances and he's he's pursuing something
similar to the Trump path in 2016 in
terms of ways to stand out maybe it will
benefit him he was so severely attacked
last night at the debate I'm not I'm not
sure which way it goes or if his numbers
move at all DeSantis he he did a great
job doing the disantis performance which
is to seem very disciplined very
competent have a clear political vision
and just not be that sexy you know being
being Trump with perhaps more discipline
and less sexiness to some people sounds
great but to a lot of people it doesn't
doesn't do very much Nikki I think
probably hurt herself Tim I think
probably hurt herself a little bit was
there anyone else on stage oh Chris
Chris Christie Chris Christie was not
did not have a good performance did not
look good tried to fuse zingers out at
Trump didn't they didn't quite land so
where does that leave us in basically
the exact same place that we were before
the debate happened